already works your way through the
PlayStation 4 line up never fear Sony
fans are over 100 new games coming to
the PlayStation 4 this year I'm mark
Walton and welcome to another gamespot
news update sony has published a master
list of over 100 ps4 games it'll be
available by the end of the year the
list includes previously released titles
like Metal Gear Solid 5 ground zeroes
and thief as well as highly anticipated
titles like destiny Assassin's Creed
unity and yes finally for you us folks
the graphical gameplay powerhouse that
is the all-new backgammon blitz not
wanting to get anyone too excited over
the possibilities of a high-definition
realistically modeled set of backgammon
dice sony also listed evolution studios
long-delayed racing game drive club as
TBA the list also doesn't include this
year's call of duty title from
sledgehammer games presumably because
they're all playing backgammon blitz
which ps4 games are you most excited
about check out the full list over on
gamespot and let us know in the comments
below see you next time
you